[Musik]
o
herzlich willkommen in sallys welt heute
gibt es mal wieder eine auszeit torte
denn die hochzeitssaison die kommt schon
bald und ich weiß von vielen paaren die
die hochzeit die letzten zwei jahre
verschoben haben dass sie diese sachen
werden und deswegen braucht ihr glaube
ich mal wieder eine topten inspiration
dieses mal wird es noch moderne eckige
torte ich bin selber schon gespannt
drauf denn ich habe mir zwar jetzt schon
ein bisschen überlegt wie sie
geschmacklich sein soll aber optisch
doch coco ist einfach mal als ich habe
so eine kleine vorstellung zur chemie
naked cache mit schönen details aber da
komme ich jetzt einfach mal als ich
benutz dafür diese kleinen backformen
und zwar sind es die mini programmen und
damit werden eine schöne moderne hohe
torte gestalten ich werde jetzt erst mal
einen kuchen backen und zwar kennt ihr
vielleicht schon den mangel rührkuchen
von meinem blog das ist ein basic rezept
was ihr wirklich für nahezu alle motiv
torten verwenden könnt und stadt mandeln
könnt ihr jederzeit haselnüsse erdnüsse
kokosnüsse usw alles mögliche verwendet
der erste boden also der teig wird jetzt
für den kleinen kuchen für den oberen
part und dafür mache ich jetzt einen
kubus boden das sag ich mal die zutaten
für den teig nämlich 350 gramm zucker
etwas salz und vanille extrakt jeweils
150 gramm butter milch und
sonnenblumenöl 100 gramm kokosflocken
oder kokosraspeln und 225 gramm mehl
backpulver oder ihr verwendet einfach
mein back melder ist backpulver schon
mit drin und ihr müsst es nicht mehr
sieben und nicht vermischen weil es
einfach perfekt dosiert ist gebt ihr
einfach ich halte es jetzt auch ein
bisschen schneller und kürzer weil der
teig später genauso zubereitet wird gibt
jetzt einfach die eier mit dem zucker
salz und vanille extrakt in die
rührschüssel das verrät er dann schön
schaumig so etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
danach gibt ihr die beiden flüssigkeiten
nämlich buttermilch und sonnenblumenöl
ganz kurz nur dazu unsere dann zum
schluss noch die kokosraspeln und das
back mail ein das war's schon
[Musik]
sobald mehr dabei ist nicht mehr so
lange rühren sondern nur ganz kurz
unterrühren und jetzt habe ich hier
meine zwei backformen die sind beide auf
15 mal 15 zentimeter eingestellt ihr
könnt auch jederzeit wenn ihr doch einen
runden kuchen machen wollte eine andere
größe einfach in meine app gehen da
könnt ihr euch nämlich die backformen
einfach oder die zutaten einfach auf
eure backform größe ausrechnen lassen
also lasst euch davon nicht irritieren
und ich packe es gleich in zwei
backformen damals eben schneller geht
wenn ich die menge auf teile
[Musik]
tapezieren allen back ringen und
backformen immer innen so eine innen
skalierung und da könnt ihr ablesen
gerade wenn ihr zwei formen befüllt ob
die höhe eben optimal gleich ist jetzt
habe ich gleichmäßig fehlt drin und kann
den kuchen backen und in der
zwischenzeit werde ich mich schon mal um
den zweiten boden kümmern oder
dachboden ach lass dich überraschen
[Musik]
für die erfüllung nämlich 200 gramm ihn
wären eine zitrone davon brauche ich den
abrieb und den saft 380 gramm zucker
einen teelöffel stärke und 150 gramm
kalte butter es wurde also doch die
schulung jetzt mache ich erstmal eine
himbeere zitronencreme nämlich ein
himbeer zitronen kirk sowie das leben
gehört nur eben noch fruchtiger durch
die himbeeren und ihr könnt jetzt
frische oder gefrorene nehmen wenn
gerade keine saison ist nämlich auf
jeden fall immer die gefrorenen die habe
ich auch immer da das ganze jahr über
und bin da einfach so ein bisschen
flexibler drehte ich erstmal die
himbeeren da rein in den topf das muss
ja ziemlich gekocht werden und da kommt
der abrieb der zitrone dazu die sollte
auf jeden fall gewaschen sein
umgespritzt so dass man einfach die
schale verzehren kann
ich schneide ich ging es immer ganz
gerne hierhin
den zitrone weg denn dann kann man sie
einfach besser auspressen und bekommt
noch mehr saft raus
geflogen
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es hier einfach noch die eier
den zucker und die stärke dazu und
verrührt alles und dürfte es dann erst
einmal verrühren da weiter stampfen und
schön aufkochen
[Musik]
wenn es dann auf kochen durfte
könnt ihr direkt nehmen ist auch ein
bisschen eingedickt das ist perfekt ich
möchte diese hin becker nicht mit drin
haben deswegen streiche ich durch ein
sieb fahrzeug zerstört durch das auch
gerne drin lassen aber ich finde in so
einer torte gerade unsere feinen torte
dürfen die kerne gerne raus
und dann drehte ich hier jetzt in dieses
warme hinweg hört einfach noch die kalte
butter 1 und damit bewegt er auch dass
die masse eben schön schnell wieder
abkühlt hat man nicht so lange
wartezeiten
[Musik]
meine hinweise drogen gehört ist jetzt
fertig ich werde jetzt gleich in gläser
abfüllen und verschrauben und kalt
stellen dann ist es nämlich für die
torte bereit und dann kann ich jetzt
schon mal die zweite tor zu machen und
das wird eine erdnuss schokoladentorte
mit karamell für die erdnuss würden
nämlich sechs eier 300 gramm koks blüten
zucker etwas wandel extrakt jeweils 300
gramm butter milch und sonnenblumenöl
zwar von euch noch mehr wisse die sind
gesalzen
450 gramm back mail oder mehl und
backpulver und 100 grad kaunitz hierbei
muss boden nämlich jetzt kokos blüten
zucker weil der einfach so ein bisschen
dunkler ist von der farbe und auch ein
bisschen malt sich schmeckt es passt
ganz gut die erdnüsse sind gesalzen
deswegen verzichte ich auf salz und
kakao nix die sind der hammer denn die
schmecken total schokoladig weil es
einfach die gebrochene kakaobohne ist
und aber keinen zucker beinhalten als
mag so eine bittere schokolade not denn
hier gehe ich jetzt genauso formen der
zubereitung des teiges als ich werd die
eier mit dem zucker und wann den extrakt
extrem schaumig rühren dann die
buttermilch und das öl zu fügen die
ergebnisse werden dann noch im mixer
zerkleinert so dass ich einfach
gemahlene erdnüsse habe und dann wird
alles nur noch kurz ein gerührt und auch
wieder auf zwei programmen verteilt
[Musik]
aus wie erdnussbutter eine riesen
schüssel voll erdnussbutter
ihr könnt übrigens immer die ergebnisse
wenn ihr die malen wolf mit ein bisschen
mehr vermischen denn wenn er so nur
richtig hochleistungs mixa habt dann
kannst ganz schnell passieren dass sie
etwas muss macht stadt gehabt gemahlene
erdnüsse und dann vermisse ich das
einfach immer und dann ist das bisschen
trockener und die erdnüsse werden eben
schweizer mal und dafür nehme ich jetzt
den bug rahmen und stellen etwas größer
120 cm damit die untere torte groß ist
und die obere klein
[Musik]
hier auch wieder schön ordentlich
verstreichen und dann backen
[Musik]
als füllung mache ich jetzt eine praline
flow aus erdnüssen und karamell
kuvertüre und zwar braucht ihr dafür 200
gramm gesalzene erdnüsse 300 rahmen
karamell cora türe das ist diese
callebaut hier die hat schon ein
karamell geschmack weil eben der zucker
einfach vorher karamellisiert wird bevor
dann schokolade draus gemacht wird einen
viertel teelöffel zimt und zum füllen
der torte nämlich noch cookie dough
fudge ich habe kurz überlegt ob ich
sollte kermani aber ich nehme doch
cookie dough weil da einfach kleine
schokostückchen dabei sind und das ist
schon extrem lecker ok werde ich erstmal
die erdnüsse rösten ihr könnt entweder
in der pfanne machen ohne fett oder auch
im backofen was für euch einfacher ist
es einfach kurz die pfanne
jetzt die erdnüsse schön rösten bis ein
bisschen farbe bekommen unter der
zwischenzeit werde ich auch schon mal
die schokolade schmelzen über dem warmen
wasserbad
[Musik]
es gibt hier einen teil schokolade noch
übrig behalten jetzt nicht in drittel
also es ist nicht temperiert aber
einfach nur um die schokolade schnell
runter zu kühlen hier noch den rest rein
die nüsse die sind jetzt auch schon
gerüstet gericht auch richtig wunderbar
und die müsse werde ich jetzt gleich
abkühlen lassen und dafür werde ich dir
einfach auf ein blech ausstreuen denn im
mai verteilte hitze immer ganz gut und
dann kann ich sie schön vermahlen und
wenn ich sie dann zermahlen habe kommt
die schokolade rein
[Musik]
schokolade können wir hier gleich dazu
geben
[Musik]
die füllung denke ich jetzt auch ab und
lass dir abkühlen die cookie dough fudge
das werde ich jetzt nicht ein rühren
denn das ist einfach noch ein bisschen
zu warm das bedeutet ich habe jetzt
schon die böden gebacken habe die frucht
füllung habe die karamell füllung zu
müssen wir noch kurz überlegen wie die
tat überhaupt aussehen soll ich mache
zwar überlegungen und dann
überlege ich mir was von mir kriegen ich
mache wahrscheinlich eine buttercreme
oder lang
[Musik]
ich habe ich die tomate world aber wie
sollte jetzt aussehen
genau überlegen naked bikes in venedig
gag einecke tate modern klassisch statt
kuchen und hergerissen und so richtig
hinterließen
gespachtelt nicht
mehr ausfüllen optional auch schon in
die suppe spucken ich glaube ich mache
spachteltechnik
somit spachteltechnik talk talk talk
und dann mit früchten
blumen
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit orte werden
nämlich gott mittagessen ich hatte
hunger deswegen kann ich als ich muss
immer so vom hunger sättigungsgefühl
also zwischen drin sein da kann ich gut
kochen und backen und habe mir jetzt
überlegt macht mit buttercreme denn die
hält einfach am besten und ich mache
jetzt ein swissmedic buttercreme und die
können die entweder auf dem herd zu
bereiten oder in der küchenmaschine
mittels der funktion ich mache es jetzt
auch in der kern wurde weil es einfacher
geht weil es schon eine große menge zu
bereiten werde da könnt ihr gerne auch
schon mal immer ein grundrezept
vorbeischauen das könnte jetzt entweder
auf mehr zu bereiten oder eben in der
küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion und
zwar nehmt ihr jetzt das eiweiß mit dem
salz und zucker und verrührt es bei
stufe 4 ungefähr oder mit dem
schneebesen über dem heißen wasserbad
für etwa zehn minuten bei ungefähr 70
grad auf dem wasserbad als auf dem herd
geht's einfach wenn ihr das wasser
kochen ist und die rührschüssel darüber
halten oder eben darüber schweben lässt
dann reicht die hitze auf jeden fall
auch aus dann nehmt ihr das ganze vom
wasserwart wieder herunter oder schaltet
ihr hierzu ab und s-bahn noch mal 10 bis
15 minuten kann so wird die eier masse
schön cremig und stabil und in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr dann nämlich noch
viel butter mit dem putter zucker
verrühren richtig schön weiß cremig und
dann einfach nur noch beide zutaten
verbinden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so muss die mutter immer ausnahmen bei
der buttercreme schön weiß cremig und
luftig
richtig schön und damit die buttercreme
gelingt ist wirklich wichtig das muss
schön weiß cremig und schau mich sein
bzw ich schaue mich ist dieses weiß
cremig und luftig und die bc mache die
muss schon wieder schön standfest sein
und vor allem kalt denn wenn ihr die
jetzt zu warm habt und in die butter
einrühren dann schmilzt die und dann
gelingt euch eben jetzt einfach beides
verbinden das könnte ja auch gerne
eigentlich auch in der küche
egal
[Musik]
schaut euch das an ich hatte auch immer
so lange zu rühren guckt euch das mal
die so schöne luftige massen
im herbst schon jedoch liegt
das ist gottes
ich werde zuerst einmal die kleine torte
befüllen das heißt die cocos böden hole
ich es her ich habe nochmal zwei
gebacken wir haben zwar nicht
ausgereicht außerdem zwei gebacken mein
himberg hört aus dem kühlschrank hole
ich jetzt noch und das ist jetzt eine
vanille buttercreme die schmeckt jetzt
einfach nur nach vanille und schmeckt
lecker wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr dabei
auch noch gerne zitronenschale und
zitronensaft dazugeben oder ihr könnt
auch wenn ihr da habt zitronen passte
nehmen das geht auch ich werde es
nämlich ein bisschen davon tatsächlich
so ein bisschen nun zitronengeschmack
machen
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier meine vier
böten die sind bereits abgekühlt und war
im kühlschrank da lassen sich nämlich
besser schneiden und dann schneide ich
dir jetzt einfach jeweils einmal durch
und den kleinen hubl den schneide ich
auch weg das so schön gerade sind am
besten mit einer torte säge oder mit
einem torten messer
[Musik]
und da immer schöne säge bewegung machen
und nicht sehen
denn sonst ist der guten kaputt
[Musik]
jetzt sind alle vorbereitungen getroffen
und die erste tochter kann befüllt
werden ich muss aber auch sagen
ich glaube ich probiert ob alles
zusammenpasst ich mit einem
toptrainer
nämlich bis 8
das hat aber eine richtig schöne
konstanz gekriegt und probiere ich das
das ist ne schöne und leckere torte
schön noch nicht aber lieber gleich ne
schöne kleid aber lecker schon so
als nächstes nehme ich mir gerne sports
das sind diese dünnen platten und die
helfen mir später dabei die torte
möglichst gleichmäßig und vor allem
einfach glatt zu streichen und da sitzt
jetzt am besten erstmal einen boden
drauf
und da ist es immer gut wenn der boden
einfach ein bisschen kleiner ist als die
platte das ist echt wichtig und dann
kommt erntet orten creme also die
buttercreme in den spritzbeutel mit
großer machtfülle
[Musik]
das hilft mir gleich ein bisschen
sauberer zu arbeiten
[Musik]
und dann kommt jetzt erst mal einen ring
aus buttercreme hier außen rum
brandung so sich ken ring
in dem bezirk kommt dann durch in
erfüllung
man könnte den ich noch schön glatt
verstreichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ihr möchtet gerne noch ein bisschen
mehr peter krämer obendrauf geben
[Musik]
glaubt streichen und so fühle ich jetzt
einfach die ganze branche und achte
jetzt immer schön drauf dass die torte
gerade wird wenn ihr so nicht ganz
gerade arbeiten könnt weil er vielleicht
torten für anfänger seid könnt ihr auch
gerne den torten rahmen wieder aus nur
umsetzen dann habt ihr nämlich einfach
schon mal die geraten seiten und könnt
dann für
[Musik]
lieber darauf achten dass es schön
gerade ist auch beim befüllen
[Musik]
ich bin gerade dort es reicht das wird
sonst so hoch also letzter boden
unternehmt ihr immer den flachen boden
so sieht sehr gut aus von daher das
heißt ich habe jetzt nur drei kokos
böden gebraucht die zwei sind
tatsächlich üblich und jetzt lege ich
hier nochmal das andere garching bot
drauf so könnt ihr auch immer schauen
dass die torte gerade ist ihr können
auch gerne eine wasserwaage drauflegen
zutaten muss anfangen
und dann werde ich die torte nämlich
erst einmal einpacken in den bug ring er
in den back reymondin setzt sich wieder
außen rum wenn ihr möchtet gerne mit
folie dazwischen mit einer torte rand
folie damit einfach nicht also das
einfach die creme jetzt nicht an meiner
back haben festklebt und da musst du
erstmal in die kühlung denn ansonsten
ist sie nicht so stabil aber die butter
wird ja auch gleich fest das heißt die
kommt so schön eingepackt den
kühlschrank kann fest werden und ich
werde noch mal eine creme zu bereiten
für meine große untere pforte
das anstrengendste an hochzeitstorten
ist echtes innenleben also da zählt die
innere schönheit muss ich echt sagen
denn bis man da einfach mal die böden
hat die füllung und alles schön
geschichtet hat ist ein ganzer tag
vorbei als ich hier habe ich jetzt noch
mal 600 gramm swissmedic batterien und
da kommen 200 gramm flüssige
zartbitterschokolade rein ja mia
ganz schön einrühren
[Musik]
gut dann nehme ich jetzt die großen
würden die werden jetzt auch geschnitten
der
schwerpunkt wieder endlich vertreten
und damit das außen schön hell bleibt
kommt hier einmal die händler creme
außen herum
da die schokocreme
staat oregon und da komme mit den ganzen
krems
ich habe es meinen kindern ja auch wenn
man sachen aufzuspielen dann schotter
creme
das ist so schön
geht s noch besitzt so viel ich glaube
ich ein bisschen zu viel gemacht
aber lieber habe ich bis jetzt so viel
als zu wenig weil dann ständig nochmal
creme nach werden dass auch da können
und die kamera auch gut einfrieren falls
ihr mal zuviel buttercreme habt könnt
ihr sie einfrieren oder einfach jemanden
geben der mutter trinken
dann kommt die pralinées füllung
diese füllung wie mache ich das jetzt
die kommt in der klecksen obendrauf
[Musik]
dann ganz wichtig die features nicht
vergessen
die vergesse ich in letzter zeit nämlich
oft
mir gut so will ich jetzt die ganze
torte
[Musik]
wisst ihr das sind so momente wo ich
daran zurückdenke und an eure kommentare
denkt wenn ihr sagt warum hast du kein
kalorienzähler in deiner app
stelle für euch hätten kalorienzähler
weiß wie viel butter ich hier benutzt
habe und wie viel zucker das kann kein
wind schwach zu ragen
potter judt und wird es keiner
nachmachen
das kürze
das schmeckt zum spiel
deswegen hat auch kalorien zu zählen
meine güte
alles in maßen und butter in massen dann
ist okay das ist meine torten füllung du
da kommt jetzt auch den letzter boden
drauf
so richtig schön und da packe ich jetzt
auch torten rand wohl ihr drumrum
eine eine backformen aus nahrung an da
kann das ganze in kühlschrank und weil
es schon relativ spät geworden ist heute
mache ich morgen mit der torte weiter
aber ihr wisst was schon aus den resten
zubereitet
eine probierte 1 1 wird schon für euch
denn wir müssen ja gucken ob es schmeckt
gut was auch zu spät aber ich war
ich mache mal letzte ganz so groß
ich mache das ist extra groß für anna ja
okay das heißt die buttercreme
die buttercreme
die pralinen creme
und die cookie dough flaggschiff
und noch einen tortenboden so schön es
endlich
zu probieren
toyota kommt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oder sich kein kalorienzähler habe
meinen artikel bleibt wird
die geschmacks zu sehen können recht mit
dem berliner ring
bis morgen
jetzt sind beide torten gut durch
gekühlt und sie können jetzt glatt
gestrichen werden ich hab die
buttercreme es übrigens im kühlschrank
gelagert bis heute und dann müsste sie
einfach rechtzeitig wieder rausnehmen
sagen jetzt wieder zehn und import voran
nehmen und einfach noch mal schön luftig
aufschlagen und so könnt ihr butter
krems im kühlschrank bis zu 456 tage
aufheben oder können sie auch ganz gut
einfrieren wir nehmen was übrig habt und
daneben erneut aufschlagen das mach ich
mal eben
zu geben ich hatte einen heizlüfter hat
es einfach mit einem warmen gefühl
[Musik]
bz ihr hier an der torte diese ganzen
kleinen öffnungen und wie gesagt so
werse naked cache aber heute machen wir
ihnen wirklich richtig schön und zwar
nehme ich jetzt dafür die restliche
buttercreme und streicht die ich hier
rein damit ich einfach erstmal diese
poren verstopft und achtet am besten
drauf nämlich gleich eine zweite
schüssel
denn dann könnt ihr da die buttercreme
mit krümelchen und einmal ohne
krümelchen ein bisschen reparieren
so
denn jetzt müssen wir denn jetzt muss
man erst einmal diese ganzen kuchen
krümme binden das heißt dran streichen
und stand zum beispiel mit einer palette
einfach so ein bisschen rein drücken ihr
seht schon ich habe jetzt hier viele
kuchen krümmel dran die will ich später
außen nicht mehr haben also wirklich
jetzt erst mal schöne erste schicht
drumrum setzen
[Musik]
schaut man mit so einer tankkarte da
könnt ihr immer die buttercreme und
richtig schön rein drücken dass wirklich
alle kleinen öffnungen blut verstopft
sind
das sieht man das auch immer noch ganz
gut und jetzt schaue ich auch direkt
auch wirklich ein kleiner rand zum
garching bord da ist hier nämlich ist
ein schöner land da aber hier geht die
torte so ein bisschen drüber dass mich
ganz gut das heißt arbeitet sogar etwas
wegschneiden
aber erstmal kommt noch ein bisschen
creme an die oberfläche damit das zweite
garagen wurden nämlich gleich hotel hier
sieht man ganz gut ist ein schöner land
aber hier zum beispiel steht sie über da
habe ich gar keinen rat mehr
das heißt
das heißt hier kommt jetzt mein döner
racer zum einsatz und ich kann hier die
torte einfach etwas fein schneiden
einfach so 23 mm passt schon mehr muss
es auch gar nicht sein denn wenn ihr
noch mehr runter schneidet dann bedeutet
es nur dass noch mehr creme ausnahmen
brauchen das brauchen behindert es gibt
hier
super
dann setze ich das zweite cage der
maschinenbau auf
das muss jetzt auch noch nicht perfekt
ausbalanciert sein das machen wir
deswegen mag leichter
und dann kurz schauen das ist überall
gleich auflegt
und da kann ich nämlich machen sie tritt
ihr ganz gut wenn ich hier die zeitkarte
dran setzte
dann sieht man ganz gut dass alles was
hier praktisch eine lücke ist muss jetzt
mit creme aufgefüllt werden und dann
könnte eben mit hilfe des cushing bossi
torte perfekt glatt einstreichen aber
ich werde erst mal kurz kalt stellen
damit das caching wort oben festes nicht
warum
[Musik]
lady oscar lady oskar kennt ihr das noch
die
ausgefeilte
schon jetzt wird die torte perfekt also
wie gesagt jetzt ordentlich creme
auftragen und dann schön abziehen und
dann habt ihr perfekte schöne kanten
ohne viel aufwand
auf die buttercreme
[Musik]
wie beim hausbau ersten viertel
auftragen und dann abziehen das
auftragen und den überschuss abziehen
drei runden taten ist natürlich ein
bisschen einfacher weil man dann einfach
so eine runde bewegung hat hier muss man
natürlich gucken dass nun alle vier
seiten stellen bekommt
aber mit etwas geduld bekommt ihr das
hin
ich mache da jetzt einfach die zweite
schicht dann sehe ich da gleich wo noch
lücken sind und dann kommt die dritte
ist die perfekte schicht
[Musik]
ich wollte euch noch ganz gut so ein
tipp zeigen wie ihr torten ganz glatt
bekommt und wir auch sicherstellen
können dass eben diese zwei brocken
perfekt übereinander lebens liegt die
torte einfach um denn dann könnt ihr
hier nochmal creme rein streichen an den
rand und an den seiten und ganz schön
perfekt machen und die torte werde ich
auch gleich zu kühlen das macht gar
nichts stark ein problem
für tipps rund um den hausbau fragen sie
einfach cellistin maler lackierer und
handwerker vor ort
so kann man sich auch viel besser druck
ausüben
habt ihr das gesehen habe dass alles
doch sehr
das habe ich vor euch geheim gehalten
doch kein richtiges kurz macher mit dem
gewicht
den tipp gebe ich mir ein comeback doch
einfach vorher eine buttercremetorte mit
acht kilo butter dann kannst du auch
einmal gott machen
und die rausstrecken
[Musik]
jetzt wieder richtig gut kühlen
gut und nachdem die torte jetzt wieder
abgekühlt ist kann ich endlich die
garching platten absehen und dann noch
die oberfläche schön glatt machen und
dann sind sie fertig und bereit für die
dekoration ich muss sagen dieser
unterbot er ist einfach immer das
wichtigste dass die torte schöne ist gut
schmeckt perfekt gerade ist und dann
geht's an den künstlerischen part da
kommt der da vinci aus mir raus
[Musik]
vater karl seiter muss ich immer gut und
so leute die besetzung davon kommt jetzt
von chili
[Musik]
ich habe die orange geschält und habe
sie an den nachttisch gelegt ich habe
eine lüge erfunden
rote kerze
im schrank liegt
schleck sax aus wittlich
architekt also kleine kleine fatma
du bist aus dem spiel raus
ist ein geiler kinderreim dass ich bin
jetzt gewinnt orten so weit dass ich sie
demnächst übereinander stapeln werde und
zum stapeln braucht ihr auf jeden fall
eine platte unter der torte das bedeutet
entweder nehmen wir das garagen bord
aber das ist ein bisschen zu rutschig
und so bleibt muss ich sagen uns wäre
auch zu schade dass später drauf zu
schneiden deswegen nehme ich da gerne
pappe weil papa zum einen schön festhält
und es ist auch was was man einfach mit
weg geben kann wenn man die torte
verschenkte und dann wird halt
irgendwann entsorgt und weggeschmissen
und ich hab jetzt keine richtige oder
keinen jackpot in der größe des rings
schneide ich einfach ein stu
das muss jetzt exakt so groß wie die
torten also 5 10 15 und 20 x 20
[Musik]
wow
deswegen genau 15
wie viel glück hat ein mensch eigentlich
am
[Musik]
dann nehmt ihr jetzt die garching platte
ab
falsch falsch
das kommt hier rein
[Musik]
ok
und jetzt gleich die hier das schon mal
so ein bisschen aus
schön buttercreme verteilen
dann das skateboard draufsetzen
[Musik]
ja
und dann muss doch
bevor ich die tolle umdrehe die schwerer
als ich bräuchte ja echt mal seine
torten vage aber nicht im sinne von der
wasserwaage torten marke die habe ich ja
sondern torten werk im sinne von ich
muss mal wegen was ich hier jeden tag so
schlimm man könnte nämlich hier die
ecken auch wieder schön ausgleichen
und diese platte bleibt dann wie gesagt
und
das machen wir jetzt vermeiden
[Musik]
jetzt sind beide torten fertig
gestrichen und damit ich die kleine
torte auf die große geschichten und
stapeln kann muss ich hier kleine dübel
reinmachen das ist wie beim hausbau die
untere torte setze ich dann auf eine
tortenplatte dann müssen stützen rein
und dann hätte ich die obere torte drauf
setzen denn da ist ein kickbox darunter
das heißt er muss jetzt einfach die höhe
der torte aus messen das sind bei mir
laut adam riese
16,5 das kommt mir ob die überall 16 5
natürlich nicht ich habe mich zu tode
gebracht
aber das
ist
vielleicht sein
16 5
ich meine küchen meter starten das ist
unser täglich nein
also rundholz und stube das mache ich
kann meine torten zusammensetzen kann es
halt immer aufpassen wenn nix drunter
ist
darf man nicht an die ecke
sucht ihr euch eine schöne tortenplatte
aus oder am besten streiche dann die
buttercreme drauf damit eben auch hält
und nicht verrutscht und
da
finde ich sehr schön
und jetzt nehmt ihr eure dübel die
kommen jetzt nämlich hier rein und
dann quasi wie so eine stütze
durch die einzelne schichten durch
[Musik]
und dann kommt da jetzt die zweite torte
drauf
die finger drunter wegzukriegen
risk no fahren will ich sagen jeder
wäsche aus mutig gewesen
können wir das schön hin drehen
kann es sein dass die bisserl schief
steht
bislang
ein kleines kleines bislang war hier der
mine dübel ein bisserl zu hoch war ich
hab's gesehen wohin aber ich dachte man
sieht aber dass
ich hab's doch gewusst dass mini mini
drauf ich lass das tor wichtig ist aus
versehen oder
endlich wird schön bunt und zwar besitzt
hier schon eine schöne blumen auswahl
als dekoration wird so ein dunkles
bordeauxrot
in altrosa mission saal bei grün denn
die torte ich hoffe die wird so wie ich
sie mir vorstelle also habe ich hier ein
paar lebensmittel verpassten und mich
mit jetzt einfach zusammen wie in der
kunstwerkstatt
bisschen rot bis schwarz bisschen grün
[Musik]
hier nehme ich jetzt ein teil raus denn
so ganz dunkle farbtöne bekommt ihr am
besten hin wenn er die buttercreme in
der mikrowelle oder über dem wasserbad
erwärmt
[Musik]
schaut man dann seht ihr nämlich den
unterschied die hier wurde erwärmt und
ist deswegen schön dunkel und die ist
nicht dunkel und so könnt ihr eure
farben immer etwas dunkler gestalten
[Musik]
und sie erwerben natürlich immer nur
einen kleinen teil der buttercreme damit
nicht die ganze buttercreme weich und
warm wird deswegen immer nur so ein
kleiner teelöffel voll und ihr seht
schon der effekt ist
also immer schön wenn ihn starke farben
haben wollt immer kurz ein bisschen was
davon erwärmen und dann habt ihr die
tolle
rot grün rot rosé das mache ich mit
denen ein teil so
[Musik]
und noch ein teil geld weil die bisschen
geld stich sind
[Musik]
so soll die torte also auch sinn in der
theorie gucken wir mal ob was in der
praxis so hinkriegen ich brauche jetzt
dafür ein paar spritzbeutel und nehmen
kleine spritztour und verletzt hier
einfach die verschiedenen farben ein ich
zeige euch mal kurz
die mini blütenfülle die nehme ich jetzt
zum rosen auf spritzen
[Musik]
dann nehme ich hier noch so eine flache
blatt hülle damit werde ich auch blumen
spritzen
[Musik]
denn hier die platz schüle und dann
nehme ich jetzt ein adapter dafür damit
ich später die tülle einfach auch mal
auswechseln kann mit der grünen farbe
[Musik]
bevor ihr jetzt an die große torte geht
nehmen die euch am besten eltern teller
oder ein blech und können dann erst mal
probe aufspritzen denn wenn erst mal auf
der torte habt ist es ein bisschen
schwer zu korrigieren das heißt probiert
euch da gerne einfach ein bisschen aus
und dann geht's schon an die torte ich
glaube bei den röschen reserve kleine
mini röschen
perfekt
dem wir machen solche blumen
mit der dicken seite nach unten
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr agentin
untergrund noch ein bisschen mit pulver
farben an pulvern muss aber nicht sein
ich guck gleich mal auf mehr gefällt
oder hat aber schon sagen ich starte
jetzt einfach direkt und ein paar kleine
vorzeichnungen könnt ihr euch auch gerne
mit modelle werkzeug machen dann wisst
ihr ungefähr was er haben wollte
[Musik]
so sieht die torte jetzt aus sie gefällt
mir schon richtig gut jetzt gibt es aber
noch blumen auf die oberfläche und hier
und vielleicht da ich weiß nämlich genau
und wenn ihr blumen in torten stecken
wollte die echt sind dann nehmt ihr am
besten wenn ihr habt ein kleines
reagenzgläsern mit wasser gefüllt dann
kann man das nämlich vorher reinstecken
zum einen halten die blumen länger und
zum anderen geben sie keine giftstoffe
reporter ab dass vielleicht auch ganz
wichtig ich werde zwar einen apfel
entkernt nehmen habe ich das geschehen
ja ich werde es war ein apfel entkernt
nehmen und werde jetzt hier
da wo ich sie hinhaben möchte einfach
das ganze ausstechen
[Musik]
hey ich bin so wie ich will arbeiten
einem blumenfachgeschäft
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt nur noch das brautpaar meine
torte ist fertig
[Musik]
murat zum wir heiraten nein das ist ja
richtig einfache
hochzeitstorte jetzt hier
ich bin das cool ist in jeder nachmachen
kann ja auch irgendwelche backe leichter
macht
ich bin dafür hat er jetzt gerade gesagt
ich bin dafür dass murat eine
hochzeitstorte genauso nach macht also
ich bin auch kein ich muss erst mit der
zeit verlandet ich biete auch nicht
eigentlich habe ich keine lust drauf ich
schicke euch irgendwas geld oder kopf
und einem messer so kann man jetzt kurz
den romantischen moment und die torte
anschneiden und ich würde eins sagen ich
weiß nämlich recht über 90 prozent oder
95 prozent der hochzeitstorte schmecken
nicht wir sehen nur gut aus deswegen ist
meine so aufwendig
und
und dauert hat da immer so langweilig
als aber das ist extrem nicht ohne
aufwändige traute man sieht ist auch was
ist nicht aufwendige partnerkanäle und
der mich eigentlich veräppeln wie
aufwändig sondern torte aber du sagst du
jetzt von easy
ok komme ich probiere einfach
braucht bin ich froh dass so kein messer
[Musik]
sind nicht blumen auch essbar ja fertig
schon
sie sind nicht giftig für
vier personen ist dir eigentlich jetzt
für 100 für eine kleider für einen monat
der hochzeit habe die schmeckt ist was
genau hat er mich jetzt etwa gelobt nein
gut aber die meisten hochzeitstorten wie
werden wir mal gemacht als er das mal
ganz gut sie sahen geschichte ja oft
buttercreme aber halt ohne sowie weitere
geschmack sehr stark also würde ich gar
kein fan also ich möchte ich so auch
einfach so zehn kilo buttercreme vor
sich aber was meine buttercreme ist halb
voll sogar
schmecken auch aus zitrone der
feinschmecker und
chorus
janko kusmagk auch nicht jeder jetzt
haben wir den moment verpasst wir
mussten doch so
ganz fit haben ein ganz schlimmer
braucht in der auch bei der hochzeit ist
mir so
ich bin so gar nicht romantisch aber
immer dazu macht das bessere ich kenne
menschen die sind romantisch wirken und
das bist du
also macht ihr unterarmen schneider
eigentlich auch die schmecken anders ja
dieses jahr sind extrem viele hochzeiten
wir letztes jahr war ja keine deswegen
sind die hochzeits locations auch extrem
teuer dieses jahr
also ich will nicht sagen dass es
ausgenutzt wird aber schon heftig
und die menschen müssen jetzt auch schon
wieder ihre finanzen eingriffe sind
ungeheuer gegangen dass die leute sogar
noch nach ihrer scheidung nach dafür
bezahlen müssen das ist echt wahnsinn
ich bin echt keinen menschen das so
[Musik]
und es gibt eine formel wie heißt umso
teurer die hochzeiten um sozialisten
scheinen
jetzt nur sagen um so schon länger
bleibt mir zusammen wir bleiben nach 12
leben zusammen also wir nehmen den
nächsten leben noch mal keinen heiraten
wahrscheinlich nochmal
als dass wir das foto steht kann ich
einfach da rein ich schneide dir kein
noch so eins raus und da kommen wir
machen einfach so da ist karotte trinke
ich
sagt
petrus karamell
bitte macht das unbedingt weil er
schmeckt nach kaffee oder nach hameln
lecker geb
ich finde die thalhammer nur das untere
stück des oberen totpunkt auch macht das
1 0 ich bin eher fern von ich bin beides
war nicht findet unten ist so lustig
schokoladigen oben fruchtig
jedenfalls ist die torte jetzt fertig
ich find den anschnitt wunderschön die
torte gefällt mir auch richtig gut falls
ihr noch weitere noch drei leute gesagt
hochzeits inspiration braucht dann
schreibt mir ganz gerne und die torte
kam jetzt auch komplett ohne von dort
aus ich weiß dass viele von dann nicht
so gerne mögen aber wenn ihr wollt mache
ich gern noch einmal eine hochzeitstorte
mit von da unbedingt ja also das rezept
findet ihr wie immer auf seinem blog de
oder in meiner app ich habe auch die
grundrezepte also diese praliné füllung
das in berlin gehört habe ich auch
separat als rezept angegeben angelegt
das heißt wenn ihr einfach nur die eine
ein partner film machen wollt ihr könnt
ihr wirklich eure torten immer ganz
individuell gestalten ihr könnt einfach
bei mir in die app schauen grundrezepte
euch die verschiedenen böden anschauen
die füllungen und dann eine individuelle
trotte kreieren die es normal ist noch
zu essen heute
irgendwas richtig gemein zu meinert ort
und hat dies nichts besonderes doch es
ist ein essbarer eine essbare leinwand
ist eine essbare leinwand unter sechs
besonderes
beim gipfel auf einen strich werden ja
natürlich schwierig ist es schwer fällt
glatt zu streichen einer neuen regierung
er hat deswegen dann sagt man nichts
sagen also viel spaß
[Musik]